หนัง
โป๊ญี่ปุ่นสวัสดีค่ะครูเอ๋สวัสดีค่ะครู
ต้องสวัสดีค่ะนักเรียน
ทุกคน
ต้องวันนี้สวยเชียวนี้คุณต้อมพาลิปสติก
[เพลง]
น่ารักจ้ะ
สาวคุณต้อม
ก่อนอื่นวันนี้วันอะไรนะคะโอ้วันนี้ล่ะคะ
วันนี้เป็นวันพุธค่ะวันพุธอ่ะกูเอมเห็น
นิดนึงก็ได้นะคะอุ้ยสักครู่นะคะคุณต้อง
ปากกาคู๋
แต่กูอีกต้องทำพูดต้องใหญ่ๆก่อนปืน
เน็ต
โอเคน่าจะใหญ่แล้วก็ไม่รู้ว่าไม่เห็นคุณ
ต้องให้เห็นอ่ะที่กูเองสภาพหน้าจอจะอยู่
ที่กูเองนะคะก็จะใหญ่ๆอีกหลายวันนี้วัน
วันพุธใช่ไหม
r-one พุทธสีสีอะไรคะสีเขียวสีเขียวอ่ะ
อ่า
วันพุธนะคะวันที่เท่าไหร่คะ
22 ค่ะ
เดือนอะไรคะ
มิถุนายนค่ะ
มิถุนายนปีพตอะไรคะ
2565 ค่ะ
2565 ปีคศอะไรคะ
2022 ค่ะ
2022 นะคะ
ต้องตอนนี้เวลากี่โมงคะตอนนี้
8:00 น 19 นาทีค่ะภูมิ 19 นถ้าคุณค่ะผู้
เอกก็ต้องพูดกันจนถึงกีบขา
สองทุ่ม 29  39  49 นาทีน 49 นาทีไปค่ะ
ชั่วโมงใช่ไหมคะค่ะถึงชั่วโมงนะคะ
กูต้องคนนี้สบายดีไหมคะผู้ต้องมาสบายดี
แข็งแรงครูเอ๋นะคะคู๋อะร่างกายแข็งแรงค่ะ
ปากคุณต้นได้ยินเสียงครูเอ๋พูดแล้วเสียง
แหบเสียงแถมใช่ไหม
แอบแอบสวัสดีค่ะ
เสียงแถบน่าจะคุยพูดมากอ๋อ
วันนี้ครูเอ๋พูดกี่ชั่วโมงคะชั่วโมงนี้
ช่วงที่ 6 นะเฮ้อ
ยกมาร์ท
โอ๊ยเจ็บคอเธอคิดถ้าเป็นวันจันทร์วันพุธ
วันวันจันทร์วันพุธจะพูดมากนะคะวันอังคาร
พูดนิดหน่อย
วัน
พฤหัสบดี
วันพฤหัสบดี 3 เนาะเป็นรักวันนะคะแล้วแต่
วันจันทร์พูดเนี่ยจะพูดมากๆสุขด้วย
ทุกวันเลยค่ะ
จันทร์พุธศุกร์
มีเบรควันเสาร์วันเสาร์ 1 วันเท่านั้นไม่
พูด
ว่าค่ะกูเองต้องดื่มน้ำนี่ค่ะมีน้ำมีน้ำ
น้ำร้อนๆแล้วก็ดู
ดีค่ะน้ำดื่มน้ำพูดออกเดี๋ยวกูเอาจะมีรูป
ให้กูต้องดูว่าแต่ถ้ามีรูปให้คุณต้อมดู
เมื่อกี้คุณต้องโฟเซ่นตัวเองนะ
เหมือนกันเลยกูเอกก็เพราะเส้น
เด็กนอนนิดนึง
เด้อเดี๋ยวคุณเอ๋จะมีรูปให้คุณต้อมดูแล้ว
ให้กูต้องถามกูต้องว่าคิดถึงอะไรกูต้อง
เคยขี้ค่ะ
นี่กูต้องคุยมีรูปอันนี้นะคะมาไหมแล้ว
ขอกูตั้ม
หินรูปแบบนี้รู้ไหมงานอะไรรู้ค่ะงานวัด
งานวัดเดี๋ยวเดี๋ยวเดี๋ยวเดี๋ยวๆคุณต้อง
เป็นคนกรุงเทพฯใช่ไหมคะพอคนที่กรุงเทพมี
งานวัดไหมนี่กรุงเทพมีงานวัดถ้าครูเอ๋โง่
เพราะว่า
ครูเอ๋ใช่นี่งานวัดกูไอ้รุ่นหลังรู้จัก
อันนี้เท่านั้นวัดนี้ที่กรุงเทพฯเอ้าวัด
ภูเขาทองครับในค่ะครูเอ๋ไม่ไม่รู้เมื่อ
ก่อนไม่รู้ว่ากรุงเทพมีงานวัด
เพราะว่าไม่ค่อยเห็น
เอ๋เป็นคนต่างจังหวัดไม่ใช่
กรุงเทพฯไม่ใช่คุณเทพก็จะมีงานวัดบ่อยๆ
แต่ตอนหลังก็เอ้ยมีวัดภูเขาทองวัดนี้วัด
ภูเขาทองชื่อว่ากูเขาทองหรือว่าสระเกศวัด
สระเกศค่ะและคนไทยเรียกวัดภูเขาถูกเขาทอง
เพราะว่าสู่อุ่นสูงๆใช่มั้ยเจดีย์นะตรง
เจดีย์ค่ะนักเรียนเจดีย์เนี่ยอยู่สูงๆ
เหมือนอยู่ที่ภูเขาเนาะ
ก็เลยเรียกวัดภูเขาทองจริง
ณวัดสระเกศ
ระบบพูดวัดสระเกศบางคนก็ไม่รู้จัก
วัดภูเขาทองโอเครู้ว่ามีที่นี่วัดอื่นๆมี
ไหมคะวัดอื่นๆก็มีค่ะงมีมีแต่อาจจะเป็น
วัดที่อยู่นอกนอกเมืองรอบๆเมืองใช่ไหมคะ
อยู่รอบรอบกรุงเทพฯค่ะคุณเอ๋จะมีงานวัด
นี่ที่งานวัดและโดยปกตินะคะคือต้อมเวลา
ครูเอกคิดถึงงานวัดน่ะต้องมีชิงช้าใช่ไหม
ให้ค่าสิ่งช้าแล้วก็ก็อันนี้ที่คุยกับจำ
ได้นักเรียนอ่ะก็จะมีอ่ะอ่ารุปครูเล็กๆ
หน่อยนี่ตาป่าว
อันนี้เป็นอะไรคะ
ยิงปืนค่ะยิงปืนจริงไหมไม่ใช่ค่ะเป็นอะไร
มาเป็นคลาสสิคปืนอัดลมถ้า
คะแล้วก็ตรงนี้เป็น
พรุ่งนี้เขาจะเป็นเป็นเป็นพลาสติกใช่มั้ย
ฮะให้ข้าแล้วก็มีลมดันออกไปนะคะค่ะผู้
หญิงอะไรคะตรงนี้คุณต้อม
เป็นตุ๊กตาตัวเล็กๆถ้าตุ๊กตานะคะใช่ค่ะ
ไม่มีตุ๊กตาบาร์บี้เอ้ามีด้วยเราไม่ได้ไป
ยิงมาใช่มั้ยฮะ
กูต้องเคยเล่นมั้ยคะเกมยิงปืนที่งานวัด
เนี่ยค่ะ
เล่นค่ะได้ตุ๊กตาไว้ไม่ได้ค่ะ
เหมือนกัน
จริงต้องยิงไม่โดนค่ะไม่โดนค่ะ
สนุกๆเนาะสนุกๆๆค่ะไม่ได้กูเองรู้ไหมคะ
เขาต้องยิงตุ๊กตาเนี่ยค่ะให้มันล้มอ่า 3
ตัวถึงจะได้รางวัล
กูเองไม่ได้เล่นนานแล้วแล้วก็ไม่เคยได้
รางวัล
ถ้าร้องล้ม 1 ตัวตุ๊กตาเนี้ยค่ะเรายิง
แล้วก็ล้มตัวไม่ได้รางวัลนะคะนี้ต้องยิง 3
ตัวแล้วในเนี้ยนายในปุ๊บ
ในในแค่ไหนนะกระจาดน่ะค่าปักค่าอัตรานะฮะ
ค่ะพลาสติกเนี่ยเขาจะมีลูกยางคลิกลูกยาง
เนาะส่วนเข้าไปน่ะอ้ะให้เรากี่อันคะมี
เยอะค่ะ
อ่าน 6 อัน r-mar น 5 อัน 6 ตันแต่เรา
ซึ่งยิงให้ล้มได้ 3 ตัว
ครูต้อมคุณต้องยิงตุ๊กตาเล่นโอ้นี่ตัว
นี่หึไม่โดนค่ะเก่งแล้วค่ะเก่งแล้วนะยิ่ง
ก็ฝาผนังโดนถ้าชื่อว่าตอนนี้โดนทวิต
กูต้อง 1 ตัวก็เก่งแล้ว
มากๆนะครูเห็นกูอีกเคยจริงแล้วไม่โดนเลย
ก็มี
[เพลง]
น้ำชอบชิงช้ากอีเมล์แล้วค่ะ
ช้าสวรรค์ค่ะคุณต้องขึ้นเป็นนั่งในนี้ล่ะ
คะใช่ค่ะอันนี้สนุกโอ้ยกูต้องไม่กลัวสูงๆ
ค่ะไม่กลัวค่ะ
สินค้าสวรรค์ไหมคะเขาจะพาขึ้นไปถึงสวรรค์
เลยค่ะนี่คือสวรรค์ร้าย
ไม่รู้ตอนนี้กี่บาท 50 บาทได้ไหมอ่ะให้
คุยเด็กๆเนี่ยอา 3 บาท 5 บาทซิมนะหาอ่า
โตขึ้นมาหน่อยก็ยี่สิบบาทห้าวันนี้ไม่รู้
เท่าไหร่เน๊าะตอนนี้ไม่รู้อาจจะ 20 บาท
นี้จะ 20 บาทนะออกใกล้ๆบ้านกูเองมีเดี๋ยว
พวกเดี๋ยวพรุ่งนี้กูแอบไปถามโอเคหนึ่ง
ก่อนอ่ะ
เกมนี้ช้อนปลามีปลาแล้วก็อ๋อ
เป็นที่ช้อนที่เป็นกระดาษถ้าต่างหลุด
พับดาดขาดเลยกูเองกูตั้งเคยเล่นไหมค่ะอัน
นี้พรุ่งนี้เล่นค่ะ
ปากเร็วมากแล้วกูต้องได้ปลาไหมไม่ใช่ค่ะ
กระดาษขาดขาด
คู๋นะเล่นไปเสร็จครั้งไม่ได้เลยสักตัวไม่
ได้อ่ะกูเอกกระดาษมันจะขาดขอ
แนะนำมึงอ่ะใช่กระดาษแบบ
โดนน้ำก็ไปแล้วอ่ะแต่คนที่ช้อนได้นี่เก่ง
มากนะน้องบุ้งใช่ไหมคะ
กุ้งใช่ไหมคะนี่ปลาเนี้ยปลาหรือกุ้งปลา
ปลาปลาอ๋อมันตุ๊กไว้เร็วมากวาย
อยู่มากให้
คุยเคยเล่น 1 ครั้งคุณต้องกูต้องไปเล่น
กี่ครั้งคะ
จะไม่ได้ค่ะแต่เล่นทุกครั้งที่ไปขอกูเอง
เคยไปแล้วก็ก็แค่ครั้งเดียวแต่ครั้งเดียว
คือสิบครั้งจ่ายเงิน
จ่ายเงินแล้วก็เล่นสิบครั้งเสร็จโอเคเลิก
หมดหมดแล้วไม่มีเงิน
ไม่เก่งนะคะกูต้องได้เห็นอันนี้ทีไรต้อง
ไปเล่นใช่ไหมคะค่ะสนุกนะจริงๆนี้ดีนะครับ
คือที่เอารูปงานวัดมาให้คุณต้อมดูเนี่ย
เวลาคุณต้องเห็นแล้วคิดถึงไหมคะคิดถึงงาน
วัดไหม
คิดถึงงานวัดนะคะอย่าก่อนไปตอนเด็กๆนะคะ
ยี่กูต้มอยากจะไปนานวัดอีกไหมคะอยากไปค่ะ
ไปใช่ไหมคะงั้นกูต้องมาค่ะมาหายเหศักดิ์
พากูต้องไปด้วยกันเหรอคะ
โอเค
ปากซอยบ้านครูเอ๋มีงานวัดครูต้อม
แปลว่างานวัดปากซอยบ้านกูเอ๋ไม่มียิงปืน
ไม่มีช้อนปลา
แล้วก็ไม่ใช่วัด
ทำไมแล้วจัดที่ไหนคะมีงานวัดแต่ไม่ใช่วัด
มีอีกมีแนะนำเป็นซุปเปอร์แล้วก็มีลานมี
ร้านกว้างๆนะคะ
พี่ดูแป๊บเคเป็นเป็นซุปเปอร์ที่หน้าบ้าน
นะคะข้างหน้าบ้านกูเองเขามีมีซุปเปอร์
Supermarket
Lotus ไปเนาะค่ะอ่ะดอกไม้ใช่ไหมดอกบัว
ใช่ไหม
อ่าแล้วข้างหน้าตรงๆนี้เป็นถนนนะคะถนน
เราก็ข้างบนข้างบนเนี่ยเป็น BTS แล้วน้อ
[เพลง]
พี่น้องก็จะมีไม่มีไม่มีจริงปืนยิงนิด
หน่อย
เดี๋ยวคู่เอกจะให้กูต้องดูนี่นี่แล้วโหไป
พรุ่งนี้เลยมาๆๆกูต้มมันคือครูเอ๋อยู่
บ้านใช่ไหมแล้วก็พูดแล้วก็อยู่ในบ้านเดิน
ไปในซอยนิดหน่อยเมื่อวานครูเอกเดินออกไป
แล้วก็เห็น
ทำไมรู้สึกสนุก
ช่วยแล้วมีอะไรกินไหมคะของกินเยอะคุณต้อง
เนี่ยคนนิดหน่อยวันนี้คนเยอะมาก
กินอยากจะคุยด้วยให้ดูรูปอันนี้ก่อนกี่
โมงคู่เอ๋หาขณะโมงคะก็น่าจะเป็นตอนเย็น
นั่นอ่ะน่าจะ
คุยไม่ได้ออกไปตอนเช้าตอนเย็นพี่ก็เลยไม่
รู้ว่าตอนเช้ามีไหมแต่ว่าเห็นแน่ก็คือตอน
ต่อไปตอนเย็นคือ 17:00 นนะคะ 17:00 นไม่
ไม่ร้อน
ร้อนใช่ก็ไม่ได้ไปตอนเช้าเลยไม่เลยไม่รู้
ว่าเขาเปิดกี่โมง
จะ
10:00 นอาจจะ 16:00 นไม่ได้จังนะคะไม่
แน่ใจอ่าเขามีป้ายบอกมั๊ยก็ไม่มีเนาะ
ไม่มีหัวเหว่ยเขาไม่บอกว่ากี่โมงนะคะ
เดี๋ยวน่าจะอยู่ 7 วันแล้วจะมีโง่โอเคคุณ
ต้องมาตอนเย็นน่ะมีแน่ๆมาหาแล้วตรงนี้
เป็นทางเดินก็จะมีร้านขายอาหาร
สนุกๆเยอะมากเดี๋ยวจะให้ดูอาหารที่หลัง
แต่ว่าให้กูต้องดูแต่ก่อนเขาจะมีอันนี้
เอาลืมปิดหน้าร้านคือครูเอ๋นะข่ายเป็น
วีดีโอเอาไว้แล้วก็เลยต้องมาถ้ามาๆก็ได้
อะไรแคปหน้าจอใช่ไหมคะ
คุยกับหลานไปก็แคปหน้าจอไปเขามีชิงช้า
สวรรค์ให้หรอ
กูต้องมาเลยมานั่งชิงช้าเขาให้ผู้ใหญ่
ขึ้นไหมคะหรือว่าให้เด็กเล็กๆๆผู้ใหญ่น่า
จะขึ้นได้นะ
มากไม่ให้ให้ผู้ใหญ่ขึ้นนะคะ
บางที่เป็นชิงช้าอาเล็กๆไม่ๆอุ๊ยใหญ่ขึ้น
ที่สูงนะคุณต้อง
โอเคนะคะน่าจะผู้ใหญ่นั่งได้
นะคะน่าจะนั่งได้ในนี้ก็เห็นเป็นเด็กนะ
เด็กขึ้น
คือคู๋เนี่ยเขากลัวไงเอกก็เลยรู้ไม่ไม่
ขึ้น
เพราะว่าคะเด็กๆเคยมีครั้งหนึ่งที่ครูเอก
ขึ้นไปแล้วก็อยู่ตรงเนี้ย
เดี๋ยวตรงเนี้ยอยู่ข้างบนแรงครับ
เสร็จแล้ว
สิ่งช้ามีปัญหาเอ้ามันหยุด
หมุนหน้ากูต้อง
ไม่หมุนแล้วต้องอยู่ตรงนั้นน่ะ
กูเห็นทำยังไงอ่ะก็ลงไม่ได้เป็นไว้ร้อง
ไห้ไหมร้องสิคะโอ้โห
[เพลง]
เราก็คนอยู่ข้างล่างก็ออกหมดแล้วเราอยู่
เอ่อคนที่อยู่ข้างล่างเนี่ยเขาก็ออกตรง
นี้เขาก็ออกได้ใช่ไหมข้างล่างนี้ตรงเนี้ย
เขาก็ออกได้ตรงนี้ก็ออกได้ตรงนี้ยังปีน
ออกมาได้แต่ว่าต้องปีนออกข้างบนจะโยกไง
ๆเอกตัวถ้าเหนื่อยก็กลัวนับก็ได้ยินทุกคน
บอกอะไรอันตรายตบมั้ยอะไรอย่างเงี้ยเรา
โยกไปโยกมาคือคืนนี้กูอีกแล้วก็มีเด็กคน
อื่นน่ะแต่ก็มีพ่อแม่เขาด้วยหรออ๋อนี่ก็
ไปเปิดแล้วฟาร์มที่นอนก็วาย
แอบนั่งกี่คนคะได้แต่นั้น 3 คนมั้งคะสั่ง
คนก็คือนี้เอ๋แล้วก็มีเด็กคนนึงกับแม่ไม่
ใช่พ่อกับแม่แล้วเปิดน่ะเขาก็ร้องไห้
คิดลงเป็นคนสุดท้ายคุณต้องอ๋ออ๋อกูเอก
ประมาณกี่ขวดตอนได้ไหม
ทำให้ 8 9ขวบโอ้ยังเด็กอยู่เลยได้เด็กๆ
ตั้งแต่วันนั้นไม่นั่งชิงช้าสวรรค์อีก
เดี๋ยวไปกันใหม่พรุ่งนี้แล้ว
เดี๋ยวไปกับคุณ
ครูเห
[เพลง]
น่าสนุก
โอเค
เมื่อก่อนชอบไงก็วันนี้ไปดูก็เห็นเด็กๆ
เด็กๆขึ้นชิงช้าสวรรค์นิด
แล้วก็มาเล่นม้าหมุนเด็กๆอ้วนมากๆแล้วก็
มีอันนี้อีกรถ
เห็นชัดไหมเป็นรถลางอ่ะ
เป็นตรงนี้หน้างานค่ะแล้วแล้วก็จะเป็นรถ
น่ะค่ะ
พวงมาลัยที่นี่
อันนี้เป็นพวงมาลัย
แล้วรถก็จะไปเรื่อยๆเด็กนั่นเต็มเลยจะคน
ขับรถขับรถ
น่ารัก
เด็กๆสนุกเว้ยกูเห็นนั่งได้มั้ยล่ะอื้อขอ
เบอร์คิดว่าอันนี้สำหรับเด็กๆเก้าอี้เล็ก
ๆใช่ไหมคะถ้าครูแอบไปนั่งทุกคนจะดูนะ
ยืนดูเด็กๆก็มีพ่อแม่เขาก็ยืนรอลูกๆเล่น
เด็กยังขับรถเด็กๆก็มองคู๋อ๋อ
น่ารักชอบอ่าอันนี้นะคะชิงช้าสวรรค์ให้
ครูต้อมนะคะอ่ะถ้าม้าหมุนกับอะไรรถล่ะรถ
รถรถไฟรถไฟรถไฟรถรางไม่รู้เนี่ยเอารถไฟ
ชอบแบบเมื่อกี้แกคงต้องถามถึงเรื่องอาหาร
ใช่ไหมไส้ในงานวัดเนี่ยอาหารเยอะมาก
มีอันนึงง่ายๆกูต้องมีอันนี้อ่ะ
อาเฮียกุ้งหมึกๆ
มืดมืด
หมึกไม่ใช่ตัดกินถุ้ยไม่เอาคือต้องไม่กิน
ด้วยซาชิมิมึงต้องเห็นในข่าวแล้วแบบไม่
กินสงสารเอออันนี้ตัวใหญ่อันนี้เขาเขาจะ
ฆ่าให้ผักกาดขาวของตัดคู่เอกก็ยืนดูกิน
ไม่กินกินไม่กินอ้อไม่กินอิ่มมันอ่ะ
ถ่ายเลยขอดูดูไปดูมาโอ้ขอโทษค่ะไม่กิน
เนี่ยมันโหดร้ายเกินไปคุยกี่บางคนเขาก็
อร่อยแต่สำหรับเราเนี่ยอ่ะกูเองไม่ชอบ
เวลากินอาหารแล้วชี้เอาตัวนี้แล้วแล้วปลา
หรือหมึกยังไม่ตายแล้วเอ็มอีซีให้เขาตาย
อะเนี่ยไม่ชอบแต่ถ้าเราคิดว่ามันบาปใช่
ถ้าไปร้านอาหารแล้วก็เอามาเสิร์ฟเราอัน
นี้โอเคแต่ทำใหม่แล้วอะตัวนี้นะตัวนี้นะ
ตัวนี้นะอันนี้ไม่เอานะคะ
ปกติอ่ะถ้าสดแบบหน้าคู๋กินไม่ได้ปวดท้อง
เอาอ๋อ
ปลาเหมือนกันปลากุ้งเนี่ยถ้าเขาตัดขึ้นมา
แล้วยังไม่ตายแล้วทำอาหารแล้วกูเองกิน
ปั๊บจะปวดท้องขอ
ไม่รู้ทำไมจะปวดท้องอ่ะ
กูต้องคิดว่าอาจจะมีแบบตัวเล็กๆคิดว่าโลก
หรือจีเรียเปล่าคะคุณอยากให้คุยปวดท้อง
ไม่รู้อ่ะพอขึ้นได้ได้กลิ่นแล้วก็จะรู้
ว่าอันเนี้ยตายเมื่อ 10 นาทีที่แล้วอย่าง
เงี้ยกินแล้วจะของทุกครั้งเลยจะส่งแล้วนะ
คะเอาเป็นต้มเอาไปผัดหมู
เดี๋ยวก็ปวดท้องฮะแต่งตั้งนายนานแล้วไม่
เป็นไร
ไม่รู้พร้อมขึ้นมาบ่ๆหรือทุก
ๆๆเขาก็มีอาหารถ่ายอะไรกินอีกไหม
มีแมลงปุ๋ย
ต้องกินไว้เนี่ย
โปรตีนนะคะนักเรียนเนี่ยแมลงนะหาให้เอา
ไปกินนะคะ
บางคนหนอน่ะหนอนน่ะเพราะอันนี้หรอ
[เพลง]
อ่ะคุยให้ดูใกล้ๆ
มันเป็นหนอนทอดๆนี้เป็นแมลงใช่ไหมเอ๋ไป
กินไหมไม่กินค่ะอันนี้จุงอันนี้ตั๊กแตน
คะอันนี้อันนี้กบ
อันนี้อันนี้ที่คุณต้องพูดเนี้ย
ใช่มั้ยหนอน
หนอนไหมถ้านอนไหม
ต้องต้องกลัวค่อยไม่ไม่น่ารักอ่ะ
ขอโทษขอโทษแม่กูต้องดูแลตัวนี้กินได้นะคะ
กุ้ง
กุ้งโอเคกุมแต่ทอดด้วยกันน่ะกลิ่นก็จะ
คล้ายๆกัน
บางคนชอบมากมีอร่อยมากไม่ใช่เขาบอกว่า
โปรตีนดีนะคะเป็นโปรตีนที่ดีมากนะคะแต่กู
ต้องกับคู๋ไม่กินนะคะกลัวแต่ว่าบ้านคนก็
ชอบนะคนชอบโอเคนะคะเออและแต่เรากินไม่
เป็น
กินไม่เป็นนะเวลาเห็นคนกินแล้วก็เก่งจัง
เลย
ชาติบางทีก็เนื้อหา
แล้วก็อุ้ยมีอาหารเยอะมีขนมด้วยมีขนมแบบ
นี้อ๋อนะค่ะมีลูกชิ้นแบบนี้ไม่เอาส้อมแต่
ทิพย์ที่สนุกอ่ะที่กูเอ๋เอามาให้ดูเนี่ย
คือร้านอาหารมีอันนี้ด้วยนี่อ๋อข่อยแมลง
ภู่นายหอยแมลงภู่ต้มนะคะ
นี่แหละที่สนุกเนี่ยคิดว่าเวลาที่เราเดิน
อ่ะเดินเข้าไปในตลาดนัดอ่ะแบบเนี้ยเขา
เรียกตัวเอกก็เดินเดินๆนะพระเอกก็ฟังฝาก
เอกคิดกูเอกเป็นนักเรียนจะฟังอะไรก็ฝาก
เวลาคนขายของอ่ะค่ะถ้าเป็นผู้ชายเราเรียก
ว่าอะไรนะคะพ่อค้านายขอบคุณค่ะถ้าเป็นผู้
หญิงนะคะแม่ค้าเนี่ยเขาก็จะมีพ่อขาแม่ค้า
สาพ่อค้ากับแม่ลูกค้าเนี่ยในตลาดนัดเขา
ไม่เงียบนะระวังตอนนี้บางคนเงียบอ่ะคน
เนี่ยเขาก็จะพูด
แล้วฟังแล้วก็สนุกดีเนาะเสร็จนักเรียนจะ
เขาพูดอะไรมั้ยอยากกูเอกเดินเข้าไปก็จะ
ได้จะได้ยินว่าอะไรทอดมันไหมคะคะท่านมัน
ไหมคะทอดมันไม่คะ
อย่าเว็บไก่ย่างค่ะไก่ย่างค่ะไก่ย่างค่ะ
ทอดมันก็คือเป็นปลาเนาะปลาแล้วก็มันขูด
ยังไม่มีรูปภาพมันขูดปลาแล้วก็ใส่พริกใส่
อะไรแล้วก็ออกไปตำเนอะ
เดี๋ยวเหนียวแล้วก็เอาไป
ลงกระทะ
จะมีแล้วกันมีกระทะ
นับบะหมี่เนื้อเนื้อเนื้อของปลาเนี่ยลงไป
ทอดอ่ะ
แต่การจะเป็นทอดมันนะคะเขาก็จะบอกอาหาร
ของเขาอ่ะร้านนี้ร้านแมลงแมลงอร่อยๆครับ
แมลงอร่อยๆครับเขาก็จะพูดอันนี้ก็หมึกสา
ชิมิค่ะหมึกสายชีวิตนี้
นี่เขาก็จะพูดของเขาก็จะอันนี้ก็จะบอกหอย
โครงครับหอยโข่งครับ
ต้องกินไหม
ขอคิดก่อนนะ
ไม่เคยกินค่ะแต่ไม่ชอบกูเองไม่เคยกินนะคะ
ร้านลูกชิ้นก็ลูกชิ้นทอดอร่อยๆจ้าอันนี้
ผู้หญิงแล้วอร่อยๆจ้านะอันนี้ก็เกิดอร่อย
นะครูเอกก็เดินไปเดินมาคุณต้องจนมาถึงนี้
พาลัดฟ้าก็คือครูไปซื้ออาหารที่อื่นแล้ว
เดินผ่านนะคะร้านเนี้ยแม่ค้า
แม่ค้าคือผู้หญิง
เขาก็จะพูดว่า
เขาไม่พูดอร่อยไม่เหมือนร้านอื่นร้านมี
อะไรคะบางนั้นก็ชิมค่ะชิมนำชิมร้านนี้เขา
บอกว่าร้อยเดียวเอาไปเลยร้อยเดียวเอาไป
เลยถูกๆ 100 เดียว 100 เดียวอ๋อ
สิ่งดังแบบนี้เลยแต่เสียงเค้าหวานนะเสียง
เข้าจะหวานว่าครูเอกที่ฟังแล้วฟังแล้ว
อยากจะเดินเข้าไปซื้อร้อยเดียวค่ะ 100
เดียว 100 เดียวนะคะร้อยเดียวเอาไปเลยค่ะ
เขาจะพูดอันนี้กูอีกอ่ะเฮ้อสักพักทุกคนก็
หันไปมองใช่มั้ยหันไปมองว่าเขาพูดร้อย
เดียว 100 เดียวไปเลยค่ะร้อยเดี๋ยวเอาไป
เลยก็เพราะๆ
ก็มีเสียงผู้ชายคนนึงพูดขึ้นมาว่า
10 บาทเอาไปเลยเอา
ไปเลย
เป็นเสียงผู้ชายแต่เสียงผู้หญิงได้บอกว่า
ร้อยเดียวเอาไปเลยเสียงผู้ชายบอกว่า 10
บาทเอาไปเลย
แม่ค้าที่พูดร้อยเดียวเอาไปเลยเงียบ
กูเอกตกใจอันนี้100บาทคนนี้สิบบาทหมอจะ
ที่
10 บาทเขาขายอะไรคะครูเอ๋เปิดตอนแรก
เนี่ยสิบบาทเนี่ยคืออันนี้อันนี้ 100 ใช่
ไหมคะ
ไม่รู้เอกก็คันกว่า 10 บาทอ่ะร้านขายขนม
ค่ะร้านร้านนี้แหละร้านขนมร้านขึ้น
แถวเนี้ยอะไรไม่รู้จริงๆๆน่าจะเขาบอก 10
บาทเอาไปเลยทุกคนก็เปลี่ยนหันมามองผู้
สัตว์หันไปซื้อร้าน 10 บาทใช่ไหมคะไม่ได้
ซื้อพ่อแม่คือคิดว่าทุกคนคิดเหมือนเอ๋คือ
ร้อยเดียวแต่คนนู้นผู้ 10 บาทแม่ค้า
เงี้ยอ๋อภาษาไทยก็เกทับใช่ไหม
ใช่ๆๆร้อยไม่แพงชั้น 10 บาทถูกกว่าโอ้โห
ทะเลาะกันเลยคิดถึงร้านได้แบบตะขายไม่
เหมือนกันไงกูเอกอ่ะไปดูผู้ชายที่พูดก็
วางขนมแล้วก็หัวเราะแล้วก็ยิน
เที่ยงกันแน่เลยจะ
ไปดูแม่ค้าแม่ค้าก็เอามือ
มือเท้าเอว
แล้ว
ก็หัวเราะ
เพื่อนกันนะคะ R  R
ไม่เหมือนกันคือคือร้านเนี้ยเขาไม่ได้พูด
ธรรมดาเขาไม่พูดเขาเงียบๆไม่ได้ยินก็พูด
นะจะมีผู้ชายกับผู้หญิงก็ขนมอร่อยค่ะค่ะ
ขนมหวานนะคะก็บอกบ่าวแต่พอแม่ครับขอร้อย
เดียวร้อยเดียวละ 10 บาท
รักสนุกรักดีได้พ่อค้ากับแม่ค้าก็คุยกัน
สนุกๆคุณต้องอยากมาไหมออกมาค่ะเดี๋ยวไว้
ไปหาครูเอ๋นะเนี่ยกูต้องอยากมาอุ้ยงานวัด
ของเรางานวัดดีนะครับแต่ว่าวันนี้เวลาหมด
แล้วคุณต้องใช่หมดเวลาพอดีเลยอ่ะกูเองนะ
ร้อยดียังนะคะกดไลอ้อนแค่ 10 ดอกนะคะแล้ว
ก็
ไม่มีนะครับไม่มีให้มันไม่โอเคค่ะงั้นคิด
นี้ไปก่อนนะคะคุณต้องเก็บนั่งตัวเองจะไป
งานวัดต่อ
ๆไปโอเค
ขอบคุณค่ะครูเองวันนี้สวัสดีนะคะอ่าบ๊าย
บายค่ะ
เพียรน